Khloe Kardashian standing by X Tristan
Thompson during a difficult time it's
okay to spend time with my family
et's learned the reality star has been
spending time with the athlete since his
mom Andrea died in January after
suffering a fatal heart attack I think
also motherhood just puts life into
perspective and what's important to you
a source tells ET that the entire
Kardashian family is looking after
Tristan and his brothers sending flowers
keeping them engaged and making sure
they know they're supported I think you
just re-evaluate things Chloe's also
made it clear the loss of her ex's
Mother wasn't easy for her she shared a
touching tribute on Instagram at the
time writing that she feels numb and
while this has been one of the toughest
times of her life she feels blessed to
have known someone who makes saying
goodbye so incredibly difficult
I am so happy and excited for my
daughter oh I don't have a daughter
but
um when I'm when I'm texting Chloe I
always put to my daughter ladies and
gentlemen quote I'm choosing to say that
until I see you again in heaven I miss
you and will continue to miss you more
and more every single day
despite her own grief Chloe's acting as
an amazing support system to Tristan and
making sure he doesn't feel alone you
just get through it e.t's also learning
the former couples focusing on their two
children true and a son that's name has
yet to be revealed my favorite part
about being a mom I mean it's so corny
but it's just like no matter how tired
you are whatever you just it's complete
Bliss
ET Source says both Chloe and Tristan
are extremely Hands-On parents and true
is absolutely loving being an older
sister to her baby brother adding that
Tristan wants to show the world Chloe
and his mom the man and father he can be
even more so now it's hard work for all
parties I think we come from a family
where we believe in that and you share
children with people and that's how it
should be and the two are working hard
as they continue navigating their
co-parenting relationship and I think
everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style it's a beautiful thing to get
along with each other and for your kids
to see that
[Music]